كواليس الحرب الاوكرانيه لم يعد هناك شيء
مستغرب وباتت التطورات
رهن مجريات يوميه لا تستند على خطط واقعيه
وبعيدا عن ميدان المعارك وثائق عسكريه
سريه تسربت من البانتاجون الى العالم
لتحدث جدلا واسعا في اروقه العالم بسبب ما
تحتوي عليه من معلومات وخفايا منها تخص
الحرب الاوكرانيه واخرى تخص كوريا
الجنوبيه
واسرائيل صحيفه بوليتيكو قالت ان الوثائق
كشفت عن وجود قوات من حلف الناتو
باوكرانيا تتبع لفرنسا وامريكا وبريطانيا
اما صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه فذهبت
بعيدا واظهرت مدى عمق اختراق الولايات
المتحده للجيش والاستخبارات في روسيا
التقارير والاستخباراتيه ايضا كشفت ان
واشنطن تتجسس على القاده العسكريين
والسياسيين لاوكرانيا فضلا عن حلفاء
امريكيين مهمين اخرين
اما بخصوص حصه كوريا الجنوبيه من الوثائق
المسربه فهي تتعلق بمناقشات خاصه بين كبار
المسؤولين في كوريا الجنوبيه حول الضغط
الامريكي على بلادهم لامداد اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه
في المقابل اكد مسؤولون من كوريا الجنوبيه
انسول وبعد علمها بتسريب الوثائق السريه
تعتزم مناقشه واشنطن في القضايا التي
اثارتها التسريبات لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات